hi everyone I'm Thomas well from hanging
face and today we're going to talk about
an exciting topic the future of NLP well
more precisely the future of transfer
learning in NLP to be honest this talk
is like a personal work through some of
my favorite paper and research direction
of the last few month so I really hope
you enjoy it as much as I do
we're going to talk about a lot of
things we start by talking about model
size and the data requirements then
we'll talk about in domain brushes out
of them in generalization we move on to
fine tuning model evaluation what are
the problems with all the limits of
these things and then we end up
discussing common sense and addictive
biases okay so let's start by the other
fans in the room okay you probably have
noticed the male are getting bigger and
bigger there is a nice graph that Victor
Shannon made last year which shows how
these models are just getting crazy
bigger it's exponentially increasing so
now the state of the art models there
are over 1 billion parameters and they
actually fall of that because several
models are now like 10 billion
parameters like T 5 and the Turing model
for Microsoft and you have a huge
problem with these models because they
don't even fit on one GPU I'm not even
into GPU you need like four to a GPU
just to load this model and to run them
with a batch size of one okay now why is
it a problem well that's a huge problem
because if you check like the current
leader box for instance the glue leader
bro that you can see here you can see
that the competition is narrowing okay
it's all about the same teams now
there's like Google Microsoft Amazon by
your Facebook that's pretty much it you
see there is no academics there okay
because just two models are too big the
computational requirements are too big
so there's a huge problem of diversity
and also where there's academia feeds in
currents recision lb okay another
problem that you've probably seen is the
environment of course of finding smaller
okay they require a lot of energy energy
consumed and generate carbon taxes and
so we know that training is mobile isn't
it good for the environment what can we
do and the last problem was very well
studied by for specialized means that if
it does go bigger what do we expect we
expect like to see a phase transition at
some point or is it just like building
bigger scales to try to to reach the
moon okay now there is another
which is to go the other way we know not
since this very nice paper vehicle I
really like the title optimal brain
damage in 1989 we know that neural nets
are over Parma tries they have too much
weights we can just prune them and
they're like the most recent the most
recent example is the lottery ticket
ipods which say that if you take a
randomly initialized model you can
actually find a subset inside of these
models which already has good good
performances on your test tasks ok you
don't even need to train your model you
can just take this big model and find a
subset do small sub networks inside of
it that's already nice for your task and
we see that in fact you model as well
when you when you find you model you can
remove weights you can select the waste
and you keep the performances so here
you see this example on NLP tasks where
actually you can remove like 90 percent
of the weights and keep the same
performance system ok so we want to push
in this direction so here is a small
promotion we're doing competition that
study actually two days ago which is
about getting the more efficient models
that you can ok it's called sustained LP
it's a workshop but we will click
collocated with yemen LP at the end of
the year and the goal is to get this to
the same special as the current
state-of-the-art model like birthdays
for instance and just to try to be the
most efficient the most energy efficient
that you came okay
the competition is only only firms for
now because inference is actually one of
the the biggest part when you when you
look at the lifetime contribution of a
model like the lifetime computational
cost when these models they are like
deployed in application unlike thousand
of servers actually inference courses is
the biggest part of their lifetime
environment cost okay so if we can get
better on difference we like already a
long ways well goal of getting more
efficient models now how can you reduce
the size of the models okay so we start
by this let's go a bit into that there
are many them they're mostly likes free
techniques that you can use the first
one is called distillation second one is
pruning and then there is conscious
action okay so distillation
here is a good example we made a model
called distilled birds at the end of
last year which get like 95
fancies of birth model unglue and is
like 40% smaller how you do that where
you take birds as a teacher model which
means you have a pre trained bird and
then you will train a student model
which will be smaller and you train the
student model to reproduce the
generalization capabilities of the
teacher okay so here is a good example
you see this sentence I think this is
the beginning of beautiful and then the
model is asked to complete so bird is
trained like that bursty stranger
predicts mass token so here you see the
top prediction of birds and you see they
all make sense okay you see daily life
future story all this top prediction
that bird things are possible they all
make sense this is what we call
generalization model bird model learn to
generalize okay we are beyond or just a
simple training example in this in this
sentence and what we do is that the
students model will be trying to
generalize in the same way as the
teacher model so it will learn intuitive
bias that the teacher model has learned
it's very easy we just do a croissant
robe it's called a knowledge
distillation and we do stew a person
from between the output of our students
and output of our teacher okay when we
train you can use temperature to like
emphasize the lower probability that's
very that's very common trick in unhappy
so now a lot of people have been
publishing in on distillation at the end
of last year you can see a couple of
paper like the state of the art
distillates with distillation models are
kind of very complex now tiny birds will
be the example where the student model
had to be as a smallest size of
Interstates and they try to make tuna
model also mimic to hidden states of the
of the teacher so you have down down you
have a down projection from the t-shirt
to the student they also user all of
that augmentation so it's kind of tricky
to know exactly what is the good what
part of the good performance of this
this latest model come from that
segmentation would come from this nation
but definitely people can get like very
small models with good performances
using mix of distillation and that
segmentation now let's move on to the
second technique you can use to reduce
the size of the mobile okay which is
called prude
improving you directly work on your
teacher model and you actually remove
waste from this model to make it smaller
okay there are various way you can prove
and one simple way is actually to remove
the tension heads in your transformer it
was shown that you join two nice paper
of last year one by Alina boy it's a
from Edinburgh University and is a other
by a pony shell at CMU and they show
that you can actually remove a lot of
the heads of transformer model after
they've been trained and you can keep
very good performances so on the top you
see the results on translation you see
that you can actually remove a 90
percent of your heads and keep a very
good blue score and at the bottom you
see the result on blue which is the
general language understanding match
mark and you see pretty much the same
performance so one way you can identify
the heads you should remove is by using
what Michele and polish shells will call
the score the head importance coal which
is actually their the grant of the loss
we forgot to their to the output of the
attention layer and if you if you remove
the the last important heads first you
can actually kill these very good
performance what is interesting is that
you see on the other slash graph here is
that you can actually if you remove some
heads that are less important for one
task here it's on Amanda lie you can
actually see that this exceed this is
quite resilient to dominate updation so
here in the middle I you have to power
from the data set you have what is
called the match data set on a mismatch
that's it and if we move some hairs
around at useful for one you can see
that actually it's kind of related well
okay the graph is not exactly linear but
there is some correlation with heads
that are not important on another domain
okay so which means that there are some
has actually not useful for anything at
least on MNLA okay that's interesting
because it means this is quite resilient
to the maladaptation
now you can also die out here remove the
weights when you remove the weights it's
actually more fine-grained because each
each specific weights can be removed but
the problem is that you will end up with
a very sparse matrices that are not so
good for us for GPUs we'll talk about
that later
but you can get also very
performances here is a nice paper from a
SAP team with cherry whirlwind and the
Hang Wong and they did a very nice paper
that his witness were complete rain
models as well removing weights with a
nice differentiable s0 pruning okay they
use like a are concrete distribution
which is basically the the Gumbel
softmax break okay and the last part is
actually layer pruning in layer pruning
this is nice paper by under a fan of
last year at Facebook as well
they actually remove full layers of the
transformer so this is this is really a
lot okay you remove this this pool
player so the way you can actually do
that and have the model still behave
quite well is by training the model to
be resilient to that so during pre
training you will randomly remove
weights
remove layers sorry like a dropout okay
it's a structured approach to drop
layers and so the model learns to
actually behave well without some ways
it works well because this transformers
layer they are like a repetition of the
same module okay and you have this
residual connection this shortcut
connection which means that actually one
layer and the next one there are kind of
they always connected with a shortcut as
well so when you remove a layer it's
actually less aggressive than in some
like fully connected models without
shortcut connection so layer pruning is
very interesting as well and you keep
these dance matrices because you really
move full blocks of weights so why am I
talking about this problem of sparsity
well because all these models will run
them on GPUs and GPUs our GPUs but CPUs
and GPUs they are really optimized for
dense metric multiplication okay they
have troubles with sparsity
and when you use this space model on GPU
on GPU or GPU they're usually way slower
it can be like three to four times over
to run so they're smaller indeed but
they also lots a lot slower and it's
also not efficient so you're losing what
you were actually looking for which was
energy efficiency so they're values
where you can try to circumvent this one
way is to use
what open area was promoting which is
block sparsity so instead of removing
all these weights single weights you
have to remove blocks of weights and
these blocks have the nice size that is
a adapted to your GPU or GPU kernel
which means that you keep dance metric
multiplication well you can remove
blocks but actually when you do like
strong sparsity it means you just keep
blocks actually okay your matrix is just
a few blocks as you can see here so this
helps you the another approach is
actually to make a full sparsity but
with patterns that you actually control
so you can keep advantages of optimized
CUDA kernel now the more you structure
is positive usually the less
performances you can get because you
actually constraining the model okay so
if you have like instructors pass et
usually we can keep the best
performances and all the metrics but you
lose the efficiency and the more you
structure the sparsity the better your
your energy efficiency is and using the
worse your performance is so another
alternative is to actually switch chips
and try for instance the new IP you from
graph call which are chips that are
specifically designed for spaz models
okay they are made of a lot of small
module can process data independently
and have this smaller RAM associated to
them and they can actually process
sparse matrices very efficiently now the
last technique I want to talk about when
we talk about shriek shriek shrinking
model is quantization quantization is
also very interesting we know that using
float32
using full precision floats weights is
actually not the most optimal way we
know that these neural networks they
also work well without precision and
even quantized integral so we can do
that from our transformers as well okay
it converts the flow just
4:32 the full precision weights into
integrate so we really reduce a lot the
size of our model and we use dynamic
consolation for instance where you have
a scaling and zero points conversion
and this works very well there was a
nice work by Intel
I called q8 bird and it's really working
well you can try it it's very easy in
Python and as well it's very easy to
apply conservation and a bit like layer
pruning you can do training aware
cancellation so you can tell your model
is gonna be quantized at the end okay
you actually train it in a way that it's
getting used to be quantized and so you
have better performance scissors as well
at the end okay okay we've talked a lot
about these big models how to reduce the
size now there is another things that is
a increasing exponentially recently in
NLP which is the requirement for more
data people are using more data for
training and people are also using more
data for fine-tuning okay so there's a
problem because when you compare two
models that was they were pre trained on
two different data sets of very
different size it's really hard to tell
if one model is better because it was
betraying on more data or if it's better
because usually of the like novel
architectural design that people
introduces good a good recent example of
last year was XL net the the transformer
from from Google there was the successor
of transformer Excel and exhale net use
a smart autoregressive training so you
could actually do auto regressive
training while having the possibility to
attend to both contacts to left on the
right context usually when we do order
autoregressive training on Ingo whywe so
a model is masked like the right context
of each token what Malo is masked but in
excel nets actually they do auto
regressive with a random permutation so
the model actually learns to pay
attention to both context now the
problem with that excel net was also
trained on a lot more data than Birds so
when they compared to Birds it was
really hard to tell what was the
difference
what was the improvement that came from
training on 20 times more data and which
which which province came from having
this new Auto regressive architecture so
there was a huge debate and actually it
was kind of settled by Roberto which was
a very simple bird architecture that's
exactly the same
birds but just trained on more data
basically and Robert our output from
Excel net which showed that basically
there was the bitter lesson of an LP and
the bitter lesson of machine learning in
general as reach a certain talk about it
which is that if you have more data is
usually output from having a smaller
model okay and now there is this recent
paper that we're gonna talk a lot more
about which is called scaling laws for a
new language model this is paper from
open AI and it's a really in-depth study
of what happened when you increase the
data size and when you increase the
model size we saw a change in the
architecture so it's very good it's very
good study now this is for free training
but we see the same on file journey
which is that people when they fight
hoon they do a lot of that documentation
and a good example is the Winograd
schema challenge the winner grade schema
challenge was very interesting that set
for a long time it's very simple you see
one example here you have a sentence
that say for instance the trophy would
not fit in a brown suitcase because it
was too big and the question is what was
to be was it a trophy or was it the
suitcase and the model has to do a
classification between these two one
okay so that's very interesting because
you need some common sense you need to
know that the suitcase is usually bigger
than your trophy and the way it was
solved and for a long time it was a very
hard challenge it's a very small one
you'll need like 300 example and for a
long time it was very hard to get good
performances for deep learning models on
that and the weight was solve was
actually to generate artificial
documentation that sets with some
heuristics extracting from Wikipedia
sentences where you have two times the
same noun like two times trophy and
replacing one of them by it like this
you can build with these heuristics you
can build a huge data set from any any
like crawl text data set and you can pre
train your model on that and then you
this fine-tuning on the winner brat
schema challenge after that and you can
solve the task but you can see that it's
not very we're not really happy about
that because scientifically we have not
really learned anything about common
sense by
doing that okay we've just learned that
more data is better so let's talk a bit
more about retraining first okay so I
talked about the scaling laws paper
let's go into depth in this paper so
this paper is about one single
architecture it's about the transformer
train for auto regressive language
modeling okay so you only have left
context for each talk and is that
transformer that up trying to predict
the next token given the given the
beginning of a sentence this is with GPT
too but the experiments with many sizes
with many sizes of the datasets and also
they did some nice scan on the
architecture there was always some
question about transformer which is what
is the optimal ratio of the number of
heads we forgot the model size what are
the optimal ratio of the number of
layers we forgot to the diamond shovel
models and I can show that all these
doesn't really matter as long as you in
the like very flat suite point where you
have this nice hyper parameter that was
pretty much the original attention is
only unit parameter as long as you as
you're in this sweet spot you good so
these models are very actually rubbished
to this simple hyper parameter
exploration and what they show is that
just by scaling and model size and
scaling data set size you have a very
clear power law which mean that's it's
actually exponential actually that's
what it means it's exponentially
squeezing so if you double your model
size you have this linear improvement in
performances if you double your data set
size you also have this linear
improvement but it's power low they go
over very wide ranges they go over hold
of the went on over horrors of magnitude
now you can read this paper it's very
interesting they show that to to
interesting thing for me one was that
actually that was actually there was a
failure follow a paper by Eric Wallace
at UC Berkeley we show that it's
actually better to have a too big model
it's actually better that your model is
more ready than we used to that and then
we used to to think and for the datasets
so if your model is actually slightly
too big for your data set in a way we
were as
the size of that's it on model before
you can actually get better results you
go you go down you know you're lost go
down faster and there is another
interesting thing in this paper which is
also something we saw a little bit
earlier on the pruning which is that
this transformer models the embeddings
and the layers they behave really
differently okay so when you find sauce
when you prune you should prune
differently embeddings
and layers and here they show so that
it's actually the the capacity of the
model is really defined by layers and
all the power law they observed they
work well if you remove them it is okay
if you don't take into account the
imbalance when you compute the size of
the model okay now there is a last very
interesting thing is that they have two
lows for the the decreasing glass okay
one of the lows and one of the
increasing loss one of the lows to
decrease the loss related to the
capacity of the model when you increase
the capacity of the model and one is
related to increasing the dead set both
kind of both can be related together in
terms of computation like more data
means more computation bigger model also
means more computations you can collect
this to power low and what you see on
this graph is that you have actually two
slopes which mean that at some point
they joined together and you can't
really know you don't really know what
which loss you should have okay you have
one loss which is actually defined by
our giving using the optimal data
capacity the optimal that set and one
law is defined by using the optimal
model capacity and at some point they
predict their prediction doesn't fit
together and which is actually far above
which we've been experimenting right now
it's around the pizza
Pepe mr. parameters regime and hear what
they say that activity architecture the
transformer architecture is breaking
down that's what they open yeah okay so
all this exploration of more data and
bigger models are actually related to
one idea the idea is that maybe there
will be a qualitative jump in behavior
if we get enough data okay
the idea is like maybe just getting more
data is enough to see a qualitative like
a phase transition
how the model behaved and there is some
hints of this it's a quite interesting
idea I think it's very controversial
somehow because more data as I was
thinking more data bigger model is this
video research program right and there's
this nice paper from AI - from Allen
thalmor and people at and at Olay to
Israel they show that actually just
comparing birds on robots you can you
can you can invert this a phase
transition okay so comparing birch row
better is interesting because they are
the same architecture they're exactly
the same models just that bird's was
trained on only 137 billion tokens or D
and roberto is trained on two point two
Tara seconds okay so what I was really
trained on a lot more data and here you
can see this very interesting is they
were short evaluation so you just take
the free trade model you don't find unit
and you ask a question that are kind of
like the window grad scheme a challenge
question okay here you ask it a 25 year
old person age is then a 30 year old
person I mean the model has to predict
if the was younger or older so it has to
actually compare numbers together and
use some common sense if you want and
you can see that vert is pretty bad
perch is the blue curve and Rho beta
which is the green curve is actually
like super good at comparing this
remember in the in the range of ages for
people you can see the same on size
comparison if you ask Roberta to compare
the size of like the Sun to have the
table to a house and like that Roberta
is usually pretty good out of the box so
it has some form of what we would call
common sense and this is out of the box
okay just by pre-training it's also even
able to compare birth rate like birth
year sorry like if you asked if somebody
was very born in this year or this year
who is older us which means it's the
reverse than the H okay the year the
higher the
your birth year of this was the younger
you are and the model is able to do this
sweep swatch swap so that's very
actually surprising I think now there is
this big question when you do now fine
tuning okay so we've seen that
pre-training bigger data is just better
and actually you may even see some phase
transition now what about fine tuning
okay so fine tuning means you've taken
this free training model on their data
set and now you want to adapt them on
one task okay
this paper is very important one from
deep mind the evaluating learning and
evaluating general linguistic
intelligence it's a paper that can pose
a lot of question it's an opinion paper
and you should definitely read it I
think if you want it's one of the most
important of last year last year's paper
it's like now why one-year-old and what
I say is that the reason that said
they're actually too easy to solve with
leader generalization why because we
have this training data set for the
mollow that are usually often quite be
like Amanda lie or SLI or squad they're
really kind of big data set to fine-tune
on and they give models that actually
don't really have good sample
efficiencies so let's let's focus what
does this mean let's say we have two
model we have model a model hey a as a
ninety percent accuracy with like a
hundred training example but then it
doesn't get any better with more
training example okay it can plateau at
ninety percent
but lb takes like one million examples
to get to ninety percent accuracy but
then it can increase a little bit and it
end up plateauing at ninety two percent
so if we do if we just do like we do
usually like we compare the model at the
end of the fine-tuning we will say Oh
model B is not better because it can
reach 92 percent accuracy
well actually we should really we were
Model A because Model A is able to reach
very good score with just 100 training
example that's really great that's what
we wanted from transfer learning okay
that was one of the initial goal of
transfer learning was to make this model
work on very small data sets and this is
called sample efficiency it means how
better your model gets with one
additional example
there are a lot of other problem with
these models which are related one model
is that when you find you in on these
big data sets usually we get models that
work well really exactly on the training
and the fine-tuning domain so you have
models that work well on squared for
instance that work well that means they
work well on Wikipedia question
answering in this very narrow field of
question answering but we would like for
instance we don't really want squad
models we would like to have question
answering models that would work on any
question answering tasks and this is
related to sample efficiency because it
means that if you just give a few
general question answering example you
would like your model to work already
well on them okay you would like to the
model not to need to function on full
Wikipedia to just no question so in
Wikipedia there is a related make matrix
matrix which is called online code
length we'd say that how much better
your model will get with each additional
sample okay it's an information theory
metric which actually is related to how
how much you can compress your mala so
it's a very important matrix and it's
actually probably the way to go forward
so here just a few example here you see
if a model was actually trained from so
you can see here the benefits of
transfer learning first so here on the
bottom bottom you see you birds that
strain from scratch on
question-answering so this bird is not
initialized is initial is going to be
initialized okay so it's pretty bad at
the end you just train on the full
square data set and you just don't get
very high now you can see that if bird
is pre trained already on like its usual
HP training which is the tanto bit
copper so we keep it yeah it goes a lot
faster okay so this is the benefits of
transfer learning and it reached nice
accuracy and now if you look at this the
last part which is actually a bird that
was pre trained on another question on
saying that is that you can state
already start very high so it means that
this model is actually very simple
efficient because it was already
fine-tuned on another question as varied
as before okay so this model when you
look at them on online image
it's an online code length metric you
can see that they actually very
different because when you actually find
you this model you have to understand
the birth model was pre trained now to
fine-tune it we'll add a linear layer on
top okay and this linear layer is
randomly initialized so there is no
shortcut here you will have to train
this linear layer okay you cannot really
bypass this when you use this model with
this task specific layer added on top
you need to train this task specific
layer which means that you can't really
observe effort okay and this mother we
always have to catch up somehow they
always need a few example to be able to
train this last layer whatever whatever
smaller layer is this is what we call
task specific components and that's a
very strong limit to how we can do a
very simple efficient model okay now
this was just to show you when you
actually investigates sample efficiency
you can see that it's also a good way to
see if the model is actively learning
the task using the knowledge it had from
before or if it's actually learning the
task from scratch so here you see
comparison between bottom robots all
right you know that robots are we've
been showing this blue and green dragon
diagram Roberta has some kind of good
common sense
better than bird ok and we can see that
because when we find your Obata it's a
lot more sample efficient with just a
few example it's already catching it
it's already getting better matrix on
birds and by comparing the sample
efficiency curve which is the
performance of your model while you just
use progressively more more sample to
function it just by comparing the curve
for birds on rebuttal you can see I
think you can have a good idea of how
much your pre-training was helping to to
get good performance on your target task
ok so this paper is also very nice
investigation on that and that's
actually posted a nice question of how
much data should we need and this
actually lead us to the next topic which
is in domain versus our
domaine what we would like in general is
out of the main generalization what we
have usually is in the main journal is
Asia what does it mean let's have a look
we've trained our model on question
answering datasets now we are
experimenting with like real life where
question answering is different like the
domain is different the language people
use is not Wikipedia language and we see
there is a strong performance rope
because our model is not really capable
of out of dimensionalization here is
another nice example on this paper by
thomas mccoy and we show that actually
if you train birds and has good
performances unlike your fine tuning
that's a set i glue okay you can then
you can then test it on another data set
which is a out of domain so how they did
out of the main is here is by having
some heuristics so for instance you try
to make like for instance lexical
overlap heuristics
so in Amidala you have two examples and
you have two sentence and you have to
say if one entail the other or
contradict the other okay they are very
simple heuristics for that in the data
set which means that usually if there is
not means contradiction if there is a
lot of flexible overlap it means use a
entailment so they build an adversarial
data set called the hands which is in a
transformers library actually you can
use it we have an example it and which
is adversarial so when there is a lot in
this data set enhance where there is a
lot of lexical overlap its contradiction
the good label is contraction here is an
example here and what they show that is
that they can train several birds on
this fine tune it with different random
seed okay so the difference is is very
small the difference between this model
is very small it's just the weight
initialization of the last layer and
this model they behaved similarly uh
nominally they are like various very
similar performances but when you test
them on the adversarial hunts data set
they behave really differently okay
there are this huge variability some of
them are pretty good well none of them
is really really great but some
the magnet so bad that some of them are
really bad and this means that actually
what you see in domain to test
performances you see just give you no
indication of how your model will behave
in the real world which is kind of bad
okay
here is more example than what they do
on them in a lie their values heuristics
they use to design and you can see you
have more or less variability in the
fine-tune model some heuristics leads to
like really a huge variance which means
that you can't really know how your
mother will behave in the real world
unless you be able to honest you able to
test it on real data and so on my like
small have a smaller effect okay now
it's really hard to investigate out of
the metallization so one way is to do
this kind of heuristics another way is
try to build our datasets ourselves so
we can control them so the only really
interesting Phillips in this work is the
work and compositionality
compositionality is to investigate how
you model is actually able to combine
values part of a sentence to build a
meaning representation this is very
important because we think that in
linguistics composition is something
important that we do when I say the blue
dog is going out you kind of gather blue
and dog together in a single in a single
meaning and then you combine this with
the rest of the sentence to build up the
meaning so there's a nice work called
scan and pcfg
sets which was actually a really really
long but super interesting paper by age
of two up case from Amsterdam University
and they can build a huge data set
that's replicates some natural language
data sets so they be status in which you
you have to combine instruction together
to generate an output okay and you have
to combine instruction compositionally
so you can generate your nice output so
you have like it's written like repeat
something and there's something we have
to be considered as as a single entity
and then the repeat function at the
apply on it and they were able to
naturalize the data set so they were
able to reproduce the depth and the
length of like a translation or a very
big translation that I said
VMT challenge okay so they're this
artificial data set you generate this
instruction yourself but which really
replicates well natural language and
WebRTC artificial deaths that you can
actually do some out of the man
generalization so Finance in your
training part you can remove some
instruction some words do the model will
never see them I like some way to
combine words and it can estate how the
model will learn to do that
and I like one of the most fascinating
experiments have so last year which is
called over generalization over the
duration is like super fascinating it's
it's a bit like when you're when you're
kid you're learning language and you
make mistakes but this mistakes are like
smart mistakes okay
for instance you will add Edie at the
end of a past verb verb in the past
tense but it's like an irregular verb we
say instead of saying I went we say I go
with okay and this is called smart
mistake because it means you've learned
room you've just not learned yet the
exception and we really want our model
to learn rules so they can generalize
outside of the training domain okay so
you can investigate that by putting some
irregular verbs in this article that
said so here you can investigate that
and the nice thing about these paper is
that they compared the complete various
architectures they compared lsdm they
comport kind of nets the commands former
together and what they see is the really
very important C's like Alice then they
cannot struggle with this question of
over memory of over generalization and
transformer are really lot better you
three can cornetist somewhere in the
middle so this is this nice graph where
you see on the top you have like very
few examples like a very few exception
so it's kind of hard for the model to
learn that so here you see during the
training the red means that the model is
over generalizing the blue means that
the model has lone exception and the
gray mean that the model actually don't
we know what to do
so it's predicting like random output
which is neither the role Naser expect
the exception
and when you have only a very few sample
like very few exception although just
can't really get them cornet manage a
little bit to do that but transformer
and
they don't when you have a lot of
exception the model learned just to
memorize them that would we see in your
network okay they are very good at
memorizing brute force memorization and
when you were in the middle you see a
bit something that's similar to the way
a human learn which is much you start to
have over the ionization during your
training you have the peak when you
actually open your eyes everywhere and
then you learn that there are some
exception so it's very interesting and
it shows that this model are capable of
some out of the main generalization
somehow now talking about in domain and
out of the mineralisation posed the
question of how do you measure the
distance between your two domains and
that's a very open question there is a
large body of work on domain adaptation
that is trying to show that you can
actually extract some feature from your
data set and you can compute some
similarity metrics on them but it's
definitely a very open question how can
you measure the distance like in a
statistical meaning or you can measure
the distance between two data sets okay
now you can know when you're not in the
main anymore okay so I think talking
about in domain versus out of the
miniaturization we're talking about this
question of sample efficiency we saw
that using this task specific component
was actually a problem okay because we
have to fine-tune them on each task we
have to fine-tune them and they are like
limiting how efficient we can do like
they are like increasing the number of
sample we need to learn the target task
that we have at the end and this is
actually related to the rise of analogy
so let me show you a little bit okay
recently we've seen more and more text
to text model this was tearing but
studied by this nice say swap a paper by
a bright Mack cane which was called the
natural language Decathlon it was a task
it was a benchmark where you have like
10 tasks to take at home and you have to
just they were all cast in the same
format in the same framework they were
all cast as Christian answering tasks so
if you have translation you would have a
question which is translate something
and translate this from English to
German and then you have a context which
is the English sentence okay when you
have summarization we actually formulate
that as a textual input which is
summarized
this and then you have a the newest
example a new model has to generate the
output it has to generate the trans
ladies the German Association it has to
generate the summarization so it's not
classification task like we saw before
but it's generation task
gbt 2 is a big model that makes a lot of
PR but was also very very nice paper
called multitask language Molalla
unsupervised multitask learners and
there was a lot of 0 shut experiment in
this how do you do the shot with CPD -
you do the same you actually formulate
your task with a prompt which is fine
some summarize or for summarization they
did what they they could TLDR - too long
didn't read and then they put the the
sentence to summarize and the model is a
actually train to generate is not
training so 0 shot the model try to
generate some plausible a completion and
the plausible completion will be a
summary and gb2 is quite good at that a
lot of tasks can be formulated like that
like the Lambada data set which is very
interesting tasks where you try to
predict the last word and the last word
of sentence is something that is not
explicitly said in the beginning but
uses just implied for instance people
are talking about giving birth but you
don't say it's not explicitly mentioned
in the paragraph and at the end you have
to talk you have to complete with the
word pregnancy ok so the model has to
understand the underlying meaning of the
sentence to be able to put in the right
word so this is completion tasks it can
be formulated as text generation where
you generate the next word and we've
seen a rise of models like this which
are trained to generate world and where
we actually recast our usual
classification or usual NLP tasks as
test text to text generation tasks ok
and we've seen that in a lot of recent
model Facebook birth model which pre
trained with the text to text objectives
so it was pre trained by giving it
Corrib text where you have like randomly
dropped tokens randomly dropped words or
the text is shuffled you can see all the
the objectives here and the mother is
trying to regenerate the clean text from
that ok so you can formulate this the
noising objective as a text to text
generation
the correct text to clean text
generation and they even train a
multilingual model called embowered
on this so we we have this both model
now on transformer so you can try them
and this models they're trained in this
framework and the most famous one is the
recent t5 Google is mostly famous
because for some time with a short
amount of time
it was the biggest model so the 11
billion parameter model ant if I mean is
P trained and fine-tuned like this it's
pre trained with a denoising objective
like the one with sofa board and it's
fine tuned in a text to text format so
for instance on blue tasks like a manila
I you have to pretty contain my no
contradiction and you will have you will
formulate your task as a text input
another we have to generate entailment
the word on statement or the word
contradiction why is it great this is
great because with this we don't really
have to fine-tune any additional layer
okay we don't actually add any layer to
our model we take the same architecture
for pre-training and for fine-tuning
there is nothing to fight you in on to
train from scratch which mean that in
theory we can do zero shot because no
weights needs to be fine-tuned on the on
the target task ok the model is ready to
be used on the target task now usually
this means we need to do like target
target task inform for training like we
need during the pre training that's what
is very interesting in the t5 paper that
you can read as well during the pre
train they can doing for training the
prepared model for this task by giving
some example of the fine-tuning as well
so the model knows that it will be asked
to do some containment or contradiction
between your question but then you can
have 0 shots and actually when you look
at what Sam Bauman is saying about glue
and super glue is their successor to
this task so that is actually really
hard now to find some datasets where our
key we can have a good classification
like a good NLU task where you actually
can prevent this model to which human
preferences where this model don't even
already reach human performances and
usually they remain preferences because
they are taking advantage of this
fine-tuning task okay so in general we
should I think we should really focus on
0 shots
adaptation for transfer learning like
zero shot of very few sample
efficiencies your adaptation okay I hope
that's take away of all this Diskin
discussion now let's go back a little
bit we've talked a lot about the
quantity of data we've talked a lot
about the size of the models but all
these models there are some common
problems behind this quantity of data
which is their lack of robustness they
aren't there a few thing but for
instance one is like the lycra business
when function so let's start by talking
about that and then we talked about the
lack of robust test or if we got to
common-sense weight when you find you
this model you can usually see some
pattern like this so this is a nice
graph from jason funk paper called a
sentence of korean stilt and they find
hubert with just just wearing the random
seed and they show that this model say
they are very easily fall into what we
called local minima so you can see this
on of behavior sometime the model work
now if someone themselves it just
doesn't work at all
so there was a follow-up recently by
u-dub just dodge paper and it's also
exploring when you just vary the random
seed for fine-tuning or how the
preferences of this model are behaving
and they saw the same thing that the
model are very sensitive to the random
seed and they have this they are very
easily
they very easily fall into local minima
what i call local minima is that it has
bad performances and stuck in this in
this video okay so how we solve that
usually we saw that with the very
brute-force approach that you can see
for roberta for instance which is that
you will train hundreds of models you
will fine-tune hundred of models on
various fine-tuning set up you're
exploring the full hyper bomb into space
and just keep the best one okay we
talked a little bit about that better
now that's one way to mitigate that the
other way is that we probably need just
better regard regularization okay so the
mix out paper is very interesting they
show that actually when we use dropouts
we usually use dropout to fine-tune this
model in drop out we replace some
weights by zero okay well when you do
fine-tuning is it is it good to actually
have the model regularized to add zero
maybe instead of replacing the weight
with zero we should replace them with
the pre-trained value so we keep them a
little close to a pre trained model okay
and they show that it's some form of
adaptive l2 actually and the model are
behaving better with this regularization
objective that you can see on the on the
on the gray map here now they are more
they can be a lot more complex with
polarization and all the work of
Microsoft on the MT DNN models that were
tapping the blue leader ball for some
mamma for some time is also all these
various regularization you can do so you
can do also organization where you try
to limit the evaluation in the weights
during fine-tuning there's a lot of
there are a lot of where you can do that
to realize this model but it's probably
the way you should go and then the last
way you can do is actually just to train
a fine tune a lot of this model and to
assemble them so you can fine-tune them
with multi task as well in which you
actually try to increase the domain the
data set size by gathering several tasks
together and then you train several
model that you assemble and if it's too
big at the end because you have several
model you can just distill them back in
a single model okay which is nice but
that's very complex and actually when
you look at the typical setup right now
to get the SOTA on blue that black sent
me the other day it's pretty crazy
look at this you have to prevent your
model so here as we said just use as
much data as you can't as much compute
as you can then you have to tune the
fine tuning I prepare meet your Lots
okay
you do that type notation so you will
some for some specific tasks of glue you
will start by fine tuning on W and Ally
which is the biggest at a set of glue so
you get some data augmentation you
increase that we've unlabeled data like
we saw for Winograd the schema challenge
you increase that with additional label
data wherever you can use it okay then
you can use some tricks that are
actually not normally forbidden but
everybody used to do a pairwise we're
ranking where you actually exchange
information between examples in the in
the queue and I and W and I
that's it and then you fine-tune as many
model as you can you take the five to
the ten best of all these models you and
sample them and you submit that as your
results so this is just crazy computer
and it's definitely overfitting a lot to
glue and it's a big problem why is it
because all these hyper parameter search
now we know that actually if you take
every any kind of model that was shown
by the gaba Meli's paper for lsdm last
year if you find unit well enough you
can actually reach some very good
performances but you've used a huge
compute budget to fine tune it okay so
this was actually formalized in this
nice paper by a just judge which is
called show your work which was an ACL
paper last year which say that we should
not just we should not just report the
end evaluation metrics but we should
report what happened during I have a
parameter search because it gives
information on how much computer needs
to actually get this model to good
performances okay
we talk about that force for data sets
we said that if your model needs like 1
million that sample that said to get a
good performance it's actually it should
be advocated and we should know that so
we can select also the more efficient
model and you're the same for
hyperparameters search if your model
needs a crazy high programa to search to
reach the good performances we should
know about that so the show you work
paper say that you should give these
curves that show all you during all your
hyper primates search how you model was
behaving and what was the best one we
see the same thing with standard splits
the these deaths it has splits in
standard training test which is nice to
comfort model but it's rich people to it
lead people to overfit on some sana
splits ok so the specific heuristics
that will work under standard train
split people we can over feed them and
almost unco them in the models which is
bad so this guy government paper runs
the barrack paper at ACL we need to talk
about sooner speech is also very
interesting read and they advocate for
random randoms please I don't know if
random split is a solution maybe the
solution would be to have several
standards
it but definitely just a single sauna
split is bad and people over Fitz and we
can see that because when you try to do
20 smaadahl on others plates they
actually can be a bad they can be kind
of worse than what was expected okay so
this was about hyper parameter search
okay but now there is an underlying
question also as well on how our model
are behaving and we know that they are
brittle and spurious so let's just see a
little bit what this means
Brittles mean what if we change a little
bit the input we can't see weird
behavior like this was very very visible
on on the geunyoung paper on squad they
show that if you add like a random
sentence at the end of the squad context
like the answer that the model predict
for the question are totally different
another is just lost because we've moved
this very small modification with lead
we've left to training domain okay but
our models are also spurious spurious
mean that say we really do the least
amount of work to get the bear from best
performances so if they are easy
heuristics that they can leverage for
instance like we've talked about lexical
overlap when you have a lot of overlap
on the two sentences of an ally of em
and Ally like the model will very
quickly learn that a lot of overlap
means that the right classification
should be an Talent but this is not what
we would like who like a model to go to
the semantic meaning of the sentence and
not just to stay on the surface from
just to stay on the lexical overlap
heuristics so this is called spurious
and it's also mean Amidala are very
fragile because in both this case when
we leave a little bit the training data
set the model gives wrong prediction and
fail in unexpected ways so how can we
solve that that way as well well one way
would be first to get better ideas of
how they behave and I think here
linguistics is very important there is
this nice talk by le public why we
should care about linguistics well I
think it's really the time for
linguistic to become to come back to NLP
to replace some some of the machine
learning approach
and to help design better evaluation
okay because we know that this
linguistics rules they're kind of the
underlying rules we would like our
models to learn so they are probably
good
not-not-not to try to be a train that's
set but they're probably very good to
build evaluation at a set and failure
evaluation that's it
okay now what we really want to do is to
try to provide good inductive biases
which means that our models will want to
learn these rules there will be it will
be easier for a model to learn these
rules than to learn these heuristics
which is called an inductive biases that
will that means the model goes toward
the solution that we want faster than
toward a solution that we don't want so
one idea is all the work on composition
ID that we show we know that
compositionality is important for model
to get the good the good understanding
of the meaning of a sentence so if we
can deal models that are good on
compositionality that would be one way
to incorporate some linguistics so this
is one possibility so how could how can
we do that well we can trick the
architecture of the model this model
they have this attention heads so we can
try to encode in this attention heads
some of this graph that we see in
linguistics like dependency graft or
like shallow like a Sarah relation and
this was the nice word for instance from
Emma's trouble the lizard linguistically
informed self attention for semantic
role labeling that was the best paper at
him in LP two years ago I think where
some of the attention head were actually
trained with additionally augmented data
with semantic role labeling okay and the
model reads better performances because
it was able to embrace this inductive
biases there is a lot of nice work as
well graph computed convolutional
network phrase of this work by by diego
on us pasting and even cheetah where
they explore the semantics in
translation with graph neural network
encoding the the dependency trees okay
so you can try to forty architecture
another a different way is to try to add
this inductive bias in the training data
here is one funny example it's an
anonymous paper and I hope
review I think it's very nice they try
to help Bert by providing after a
training sample for Bert like a form of
semantic role labeling so they will say
okay this word is like a predicate this
work is the first argument okay they add
this this semantic role labeling
information after the training so this
form like just the input from the model
and then at test time you just don't
worry you just don't use this you just
don't you don't input monte data and you
see that the model actually gets
improved whoa business by being trained
with this information okay they
experimented on an adversarial squad
that's cool swag that is it okay so now
probably what we want to do for that is
that we probably want to work on
pre-training to get some deeper
linguistic information in our pre
training that set as well like for
instance we can add more like
linguistically informs panel level
representation we can try to have like
more modular way to prevent our models
and this is all very open but how can we
incorporate this the linguistic
information free training will be
probably important as well an
alternative way to make this model
robust is to add common sense because
usually they are lacking some linguistic
stuff but as well as common sense there
are some limits so why do we need common
sense because we can't learn everything
from text let's have a look you know
that for instance sheeps are white okay
but in text usually we don't say that
because it's too obvious and on the
contrary we often talk about black
sheeps
because yeah because that's a common
expression okay so when you ask a model
that was trained on text only when you
ask it what color is either sheep it
will say oh I I'm not sure it's probably
black okay because it has no way to know
that white is the real answer okay this
is called the reporting bias it means
that in text we usually don't state the
obvious
we don't write common sense so how can
we help them out and learn that well
there are various way
we can try to add like a knowledge base
in the knowledge base we like hover this
shape node and we connect it with color
white nodes so the model can learn that
this is the color of a normal shape we
can add multi model when you show a
picture to the model with a white sheep
and the model can just look at it and
say oh yeah okay it's white I can see it
on the picture and then the last part is
maybe you can just tell the model we can
have like human-in-the-loop training
like humans are actually learning the
model can ask what color is the Sheep
under new human or somebody say yeah
it's white and then the model knows it
so this is human-in-the-loop training
these are all the way but you can see
that all of them involve something other
than texts we need something like more
structure like data base or we need like
picture we need another modality for the
model to be able to learn common sense
so yeah in showing has been as been
working a lot of common sense she's done
really really great stuff the first
question is what is common sense what is
common sense it's this basic level of
practical knowledge in everyday service
situation there is a very blurry blurry
front here with bias okay because some
power of this common sense is exactly
bias that we don't want in our model but
some part is just normal thing like here
it's okay to keep the closet door open
but it's not okay to keep the fridge
door open because the food doesn't want
to go Wow okay so the way they did that
the way they tackle that is to build a
lot of that sets they'll be there like a
lot of that sets that try to gather some
common sense and I really want to
highlight some of them vino grande is
really fascinating when it's an
extension now the winogradsky mat
challenge is solved okay we've started
with that later on earlier and now they
build a successor to it which is a vino
grande
they have all these common-sense cosmos
cue a lot of visual commands as I said
they're all very interesting and let me
just show you maybe if you want to be
just repaper
you should really probably atomic comets
and the vinegar and a paper atomic is
this relation database that I was
talking about okay that encode comments
and set a crowd so this
Kermit is a nice paper by antoine
busloads is about using transformers
pre-trained for someone to actually
mount this knowledge graph and we know
ground is the successor to vinegar
schema so let me show you just a little
bit about vino grande okay because
that's interesting we are building all
these data sets from crowd source
information and actually it's very hard
to build nice crowd crowd sourcing set
up and I think they have a lot of
experience on this topic which is very
interesting so here we know grande the
main problem is that we don't want
people first we want people to have IDs
and not to generate from just the
simplest the simplest IDs they have so
they use some way to enhance the
creativity with what they call random
unco words so the people in the crowd
source the Turkish they will have this
random word that they are supposed to
use in their example the example they
are writing and this helps a lot to make
them like creatively create new examples
and they also use like very strong data
validation set up where they phantoon
state-of-the-art models on the data and
I try to remove that that's too easy to
predict okay so this could be like like
an online data creation process where
each time you have a better
state-of-the-art model you actually
through new examples okay to remove them
and they show that the state-of-the-art
model from now they are like very bad
performances on this well pretty bad
anyway you would need actually a lot of
samples to get to human performances so
that's probably the way forward in
creating crowdsource data set like
trying to make more diversity and try to
filter this data set better okay and
this lead us to the same idea for models
okay the data sets should now be
evolving there should be dynamically
updated as new models came here come in
and the models are actually the same
problem which is called the continual
learning question what is it so that's
the end of the this the end of a
description is me that bird was trained
on like 2018 data it will always think
that the president of like the united
said was the 2018 president okay but
maybe
will change in the future maybe the
president maybe the like the countries
will change and the model we just never
learn this okay and how do we overcome
that well we need models that are able
to evolve over time okay but then there
is the main problem with this approach
there are a lot of people have been
working continual learning the main
problem is called catastrophic
forgetting which means that you want to
learn new stuff without forgetting
everything that you've learned before
and here you have different approach to
try to tackle this from memory to
regularization to dynamically growing
models and this is probably the way like
NLP should go forward to have these
models that I will to adapt and that I
will to generalize to other domain as
well okay so that's the end of today
that was a very long talk I hope you
really like that and the plan for now
will be series is to do like a lot
smaller talk in the future with like
more basic information so if you like
this you can say it and you can send us
feedback and we continue with an LLP
series as well